Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In early 2019, a learning-based technique
appeared that could perform common natural
language processing operations, for instance,
answering questions, completing text, reading
comprehension, summarization, and more.
This method was developed by scientists at
OpenAI, and they called it GPT-2.
The key idea for GPT-2 was that all of these
problems could be formulated as different
variants of text completion problems, where
all we need to do is provide it an incomplete
piece of text, and it would try to finish
it.
Then in June 2020 came GPT-3 that supercharged
this idea, and among many incredible examples,
it could generate website layouts from a written
description.
However, no one said that these neural networks
can only deal with text information.
And sure enough, a few months later, scientists
at OpenAI thought that if we can complete
text sentences, why not try to complete images
too?
They called this project image GPT and the
problem statement was simple: we give it an
incomplete image, and we ask the AI to fill
in the missing pixels.
It could identify that the cat here likely
holds a piece of paper and finish the picture
accordingly, and even understood that if we
have a droplet here and we see just a portion
of the ripples, then this means a splash must
be filled in.
And now, right in January 2021, just 7 months
after the release of GPT-3, here is their
new mind-blowing technique that explores the
connection between text and images.
But finishing images already kind of works,
so what new thing can it do?
In just a few moments, you will see that the
more appropriate question would be “what
can’t it do”?
For now, well, it creates images from our
written text captions, and you will see in
a moment how monumental of a challenge that
is.
The name of this technique is a mix of Salvador
Dalí and Pixar’s Wall-e.
So please meet Dall-e.
And now, let’s see it through an example.
For neural network-based learning methods,
it is easy to recognize that this text says
OpenAI, and what a storefront it.
Images of both of these exist in abundance.
Understanding that is simple.
However, generating a storefront that says
OpenAI is quite a challenge.
It is really possible that it can do that?
Well, let’s try it.
Look, it works!
Wow!
Now, of course, if you look here, you immediately
see that it is by no means perfect, but let’s
marvel at the fact that we can get all kinds
of 2D and 3D texts, look at the storefronts
from different orientations, and it can deal
with all of these cases reasonably well.
And of course, it is not limited to storefronts,
we can request license plates, bags of chips,
neon signs, and more.
It can really do all that.
So, what else?
Well, get this, it can also kind of invent
new things.
So let’s put our entrepreneurial hat on
and try to invent something here.
For instance, let’s try to create a triangular
clock.
Or pentagonal.
Or, you know, just make it a hexagon.
It really doesn’t matter because we can
ask for absolutely anything and get a bunch
of prototypes in a matter of seconds.
Now, let’s make it white, and…look!
Now we have a happy, happy Károly.
Why is that?
It is because I am a light transport researcher
by trade, so the first thing when I look at
when seeing these generated images is how
physically plausible they are.
For instance, look at this white clock here
on the blue table.
And it did not only put it on the table, but
it also made sure to generate appropriate
glossy reflections that matches the color
of the clock.
It can do this too!
Loving it.
Apparently, it understands geometry, shapes
and materials.
I wonder what else does it understand?
Well, get this, for instance, it even understands
styles and rendering techniques.
Being a graphics person, I am so happy to
see that it learned the concept of low polygon
count rendering, isometric views, clay objects,
and we can even add an X-ray view to the Owl.
Kind of.
And now, if all that wasn’t enough, hold
on to your papers, because we can also commission
artistic illustrations for free, and not only
that, but even have fine-grained control over
these artistic illustrations.
I also learned that if manatees wore suits,
they would wear them like this, and after
a long and strenuous day walking their dogs,
they can go for yet another round… in pajamas.
But it does not stop there, it can not only
generate paintings of nearly anything, but
we can even choose the artistic style and
the time of day as well.
The night images are a little on the nose
as most of them have the moon in the background,
but I’ll be more than happy to take these.
And the best part is that you can try this
yourself right now through the link in the
video description.
In general, not all results are perfect, but
it’s hard to even fathom all the things
this will enable us to do in the near future
when we can get our hands on these pre-trained
models.
This may be the first technique where the
results are not limited by the algorithm,
but, by our own imagination.
Now this is a quote that I said about GPT-3,
and notice that the exact same thing can be
said about Dall-e.
Quote: “The main point is that working with
GPT-3 is a really peculiar process where we
know that a vast body of knowledge lies within,
but it only emerges if we can bring it out
with properly written prompts.
It almost feels like a new kind of programming
that is open to everyone, even people without
any programming or technical knowledge.
If a computer is a bicycle for the mind, then
GPT-3 is a fighter jet.
Absolutely incredible."
I think this kind of programming is going
to be more and more common in the future.
Now note that these are some amazing preliminary
results, but the full paper is not available
yet.
So this was not two minutes, and it was not
about a paper.
Welcome to Two Minute Papers!
Jokes aside, I cannot wait for the paper to
appear, and I’ll be here to have a closer
look whenever it happens.
Make sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon
to not miss it when the big day comes.
And until then, let me know in the comments
what crazy concoctions you came up with!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!